c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenu sur France 24 à la
une ce soir un gouvernement de combat au
Sénégal c'est le terme employé pour
présenter le nouveau cabinet formé ce
week-end il est conduit par Amadou bas
nommé Premier ministre une équipe
gouvernementale largement remaniée en
vue de la prochaine présidentielle de
2024 reportage dès le début de ce
journal
alors que le monde rendait hommage à la
reine Elizabeth II de nombreux anciennes
colonies britanniques ont rappelé les
dérives de l'Empire au Kenya ou la
princesse est devenue reine on n'oublie
pas la répression sanglante de la
rébellion marmao ne correspondants sont
allés à la rencontre d'une héroïne de
l'indépendance reportage enfin nous
irons au Gabon l'ex-président de
l'Assemblée nationale qui a rejoint les
rangs de l'opposition a été arrêté à son
retour de la République du Congo avec
trois valises contenant près de 2
millions d'euros la correspondance à
Libreville dans un instant
un gouvernement de combat pour lutter
contre la vie chère ce sont les termes
employés pour qualifier le nouveau
gouvernement au Sénégal c'est Amadou bah
qui a été nommé aux manettes de ce
nouveau cabinet avec un objectif bien
précis regagner la confiance des
Sénégalais à 17 mois du scrutin
présidentiel et face à une opposition
qui monte en puissance depuis les
dernières législatives de juillet
reportage de nos correspondants à Dakar
elimandao et Sarah Sakho
c'est le sujet le plus commenté dans les
rues de Dakar ce lundi le tout récent
gouvernement du Sénégal 38 ministres
sous la houlette de Amadou ba un fidèle
du président Macky Sall les Sénégalais
ont des avis partagés sur cette nouvelle
équipe je suis enthousiaste j'aimerais
bien qu'il y ait des changements dans le
bon côté
je n'ai pas encore vraiment d'opinion
sur eux ça me semble être surtout très
politique comme gouvernement
beaucoup plus le Premier ministre et le
gouvernement c'est vraiment dans la
résolution des problèmes de Sénégalais
qui souffrent vraiment aussi au
quotidien une équipe présentée comme un
gouvernement de combat qui devra
notamment s'attaquer à l'inflation et à
l'emploi des jeunes selon les priorités
affichées par le président Macky Sall
pour ou marioum président du groupe
parlementaire de la coalition au pouvoir
ces nouveaux ministres sont à la hauteur
des défis nous nous sommes dans un temps
dans un autre contexte où il faut
rassurer les populations qui sont
traversées par une crise sociale
traversée par une attaque sur le pouvoir
d'achat qui sont des chocs je pense que
ce gouvernement a bien compris le
message sur les urgences sociales c'est
des hommes d'expérience des hommes
d'État ils seront pas là à tâtonnets
intervient quelques semaines seulement
après des législatives qui ont vu
l'opposition monter en puissance à peine
17 mois avant la prochaine
présidentielle le nouveau gouvernement
aura du mal à inverser la tendance selon
cette analyse le gouvernement semble
être tourné vers la
satisfaction des besoins des
préoccupation des Sénégalais par rapport
à l'emploi des jeunes par rapport au
pouvoir d'achat toutes ces
problématiques essentielles doivent
nécessite des réponses structurelles et
je ne sais pas si on peut faire en 16
quelques mois ce qu'on n'a pas pu faire
en 10 ans pour l'heure la principale
coalition d'opposition n'a pas
officiellement réagi à se remaniement
ministériel
ce lundi le monde avait les yeux rivés
sur les funérailles de la reine
Elisabeth II à un moment solennelle pour
certains mais aussi l'occasion pour de
nombreux pays notamment les anciennes
colonies du Royaume-Uni de rappeler les
crimes commis par le gouvernement
britannique le Kenya ou la princesse est
devenue reine n'oublie pas la répression
sanglante de la rébellion mahomao entre
1952 et 1956 une période où près d'un
million de Kenyans ont été placés dans
des camps de détention des milliers ont
été tués ne correspondants Viviane
vandeira et Bastien renouilles ont
rencontré l'une des combattantes de la
liberté mirima Muto matengué dont le
mari le général Stanley matengué est
l'un des héros de l'indépendance du pays
reportage
dans cette ferme vit l'une des familles
les plus importantes de la rébellion
mahomao à plus de 100 ans moutonie
matengué se souvient parfaitement des
combats pour l'indépendance commencez au
début du règne de la reine Elizabeth II
j'ai été battue par plusieurs policiers
après qu'ils aient enlevé ma fille ils
ont frappé une de mes mains avec un
fusil et ma jambe à plusieurs reprises
avec une hache ici juste là
ils m'ont insulté de grosses et un autre
soldat a continué à me frapper avec un
fusil
ce n'est qu'en 2013 que le gouvernement
britannique a accepté pour la première
fois d'indemniser plus de 5000 gagnants
à hauteur de 23 millions d'euros une
infime partie des victimes moutonie n'a
rien reçu let gavent le gouvernement
britannique est bien conscient de la
situation et il connaît toutes les
horreurs que nous avons subies il a le
devoir d'indemniser les Mao Mao qui sont
toujours là moutonnier
obtenir une compensation avant la mort
de la reine bien qu'elle ne blâme pas
directement Elisabeth 2 pour ce qu'il
s'est passé elle est en colère contre le
système colonialiste qui les a opprimés
j'étais avec un homme appelé qui gano
ainsi que ses trois filles
ils nous ont attaqué elles ont été tués
comme beaucoup d'autres gens par le
gouvernement britannique
[Musique]
lors de l'indépendance du Kenya en 1963
les anglais sont partis avec les
documents et archives de l'époque
coloniale effaçant les traces de leur
crime ce n'est qu'en 2011 après une
décision de justice que quelques-uns ont
été rendus accessibles
toutes les archives que nous avons pu
préserver sont assez perturbants voire
même dégoûtant ce n'est pas quelque
chose que l'on peut faire les victimes
du mouvement des Mao Mao ces combattants
de la liberté ont encore à ce jour des
reproches à faire au gouvernement
britannique la mort de la reine a
suscité des sentiments conflictuels à
l'égard de son règne les appels se
multiplient pour que le Royaume-Uni
reconnaisse les atrocités commises par
les autorités de britannique
ce scandale au Gabon selon des sources
judiciaires guinzuba Damas un
ex-président de l'Assemblée nationale
devenue opposant a été arrêté à son
retour du Congo il était en possession
de trois valises avec près de 2 millions
d'euros son arrestation survient 10 mois
avant la présidentielle doute 2023 pour
laquelle il fait figure de potentiel
candidat la correspondance à Libreville
de Ismaël obiangzé
dans les locaux de la direction générale
de recherche à Franceville une garde à
vue qui pourrait durer encore quelques
jours le temps pour la justice de faire
la lumière sur ce dossier l'ancien
président de l'Assemblée nationale
devenu opposant a été arrêté samedi
dernier par les douanes gabonaises alors
qu'il revenait du Congo Brazzaville il
transportait dans ses valises la somme
de 1 milliards 90 millions de francs Cfa
soit environ 2 millions d'euros
plusieurs questions se posent alors d'où
provient cet argent avait-il le droit
d'en transporter autant entre deux pays
de la zone économique d'Afrique centrale
mais pour le parquet gabonais l'opposant
a commis plusieurs infractions à la loi
pour avoir refusé le déclaré les 10
fonds et pour n'avoir pas pu justifier
leur provenance
un procès-verbal de détention
irrégulière le fond est primé par
l'article 470 du code des douanes et les
10 fonds ont été confisqués conformément
au dispositions suscitées
ont été reversés au Trésor public il est
reconnu coupable de détention
irrégulière de France
plusieurs mois de prison avec une amende
= au double de la valeur de la Somme
confisquée soit près de 4 milliards de
francs Cfa les démocrates le parti donc
guizmadama est président prépare une
réponse sur le plan politique et
judiciaire dans un communiqué les hauts
cadre de ce parti dénonce une scène
humiliante après la diffusion sur les
réseaux sociaux de l'interpellation de
leur leader une vidéo devenue virale ce
week-end et dont on a certainement pas
fini de parler ici au Gabon
ah bah la France vive Poutine et la
Russie c'est ce que l'on pouvait
entendre à Niamey lors d'une
manifestation qui a réuni plusieurs
centaines de personnes un rassemblement
pour protester contre la force
antidjihadiste française barkhane
l'objectif de ces quelques centaines de
manifestants et c'est aussi visiblement
danser la Russie les précisions de notre
correspondant à rôle Girard
plusieurs centaines de personnes ont
défilé pacifiquement ce dimanche dans
les rues de la capitale Niamey avec
plusieurs revendications dont la
principale était la fin de la présence
militaire française au Niger l'opération
barkhane est présente au sel depuis plus
de 8 ans maintenant et c'est une
présence qui dérange les membres du m62
et ses soutiens ces membres du m62 ils
ont sillonné la ville de Niamey les rues
de la ville de Niamey ce dimanche
jusqu'à prendre place devant le siège de
l'Assemblée nationale parmi les
personnes présentes plusieurs portaient
des pancartes avec des slogans
anti-français très durs et des drapeaux
russes une large partie des personnes
présentes reproches à la France de ne
pas lutter du tout contre le terrorisme
au Niger ou au Sahel en général une
position aux antipodes de celles du
gouvernement nigérien actuel qui a fait
de Paris sont principales alliés face à
la dégradation de la situation sécurité
surtout son territoire
dans l'as de l'actualité en bref et en
images la première sortie hors du Mali
du Premier ministre par intérim
Abdoulaye Maïga il va représenter son
pays à la 77e session de l'Assemblée
Générale de des Nations Unies à New York
il devra prononcer un discours pour
rappeler la volonté de Bamako de
collaborer avec tout le monde dans le
respect de la souveraineté nationale il
sera également question de la situation
en Éthiopie à l'Assemblée générale de
l'ONU un rapport destiné au Conseil des
droits de l'homme souligne des probables
crimes de guerre et des crimes contre
l'humanité commune durant le conflit qui
déchire l'Éthiopie depuis fin 2020
open arms c'est l'organisation
caritative espagnole à secouru 372
personnes qui tentaient de traverser la
Méditerranée pour rejoindre l'Europe à
bord d'embarcations de fortune
l'organisation à effectuer trois
opérations sur une période de 24 heures
le navire de sauvetage toujours en mer
cherche un port sur pour les personnes
se courent
de nouveau dans le viseur en Tunisie le
chef du parti islamiste rachètera Nucci
et l'ex Premier ministre allié
ont été convoqués ce lundi pour une
interrogatoire par le pôle
antiterroriste à l'interrogatoire en
lien avec l'envoi de djihadistes en
Syrie et en Irak les deux hommes
dénoncent une instrumentalisation de la
justice par le président
convoquée par le pôle antiterroriste
l'ancien Premier ministre tunisien allie
la raied dénonce une énième manœuvre
politique contre le parti en Arda
cette opération
vise une nouvelle fois
à museler l'opposition
menée par El nada
ainsi que les dirigeants du parti et a
détourné l'attention des vrais problèmes
du pays
le chef du parti d'inspiration islamiste
rachètera Nucci interrogé pour la
deuxième fois en deux mois par le pôle
antiterroriste
enarda et soupçonné par ses détracteurs
d'avoir facilité le départ de
combattants vers l'Irak la Syrie et la
Libye pour rejoindre l'organisation et à
islamique l'affaire dite de l'expédition
de djihadiste avait longtemps occupé le
paysage politique tunisien avant de
refaire surface ces dernières semaines
le parti est Narda lui dément
catégoriquement ses accusations et
dénonce une machination du pouvoir pour
le discréditer le président Keys Saïd
est régulièrement accusé de mener une
politique autoritaire notamment à
l'encontre desnarda après ses travaux
les pleins pouvoirs l'année dernière il
avait limogé le gouvernement est dissout
le Parlement avant de faire adopter en
juillet une nouvelle constitution
renforçant son influence sur la
politique et la justice tunisienne
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique discuter avec nous l'info
continue sur France 24
[Musique]